buck
tu te souviens de moi ta mère s'appelait
ça tu mettais du papier journal dans tes
chaussures tu est recherché je ne fais
plus à des gens qui pensent le contraire
vont arriver et ils n'ont pas
l'intention de prendre vivant
captain
beaucoup de gens vous considère comme un
héros mais certains préfèrent le mot
justice y est vous êtes arrogé des
pouvoirs illimités vous avez agi sans
aucun contrôle
et ça le monde ne peux plus le tolérer
je sais ce que représente pour toi mais
ne s'en mêle pas s'il te plaît
c'est vrai qu empirer les choses vous
avez l'intention de m'arrêter
il y aura des conséquences
captain vous avez l'air sauvegarde j'ai
eu une mauvaise journée
si nous n'acceptons pas certaines
limites ne voulons pas mieux que nos
ennemis
c'est pas comme ça que je vois les
choses j'écrase très bien mon point sur
votre magnifique dentition
je voudrais seulement comme envisage
toutes les possibilités les gens qui te
tire dessus finissent généralement par
tirer aussi sur moi
tu sais ce qui va se passer
tu compte vraiment en tirer à la force
de tes points
qu'est ce qu'on fait on se parle
je suis désolé tony
si j'avais le choix je ferais pas ça
mais c'est mon ami comme je l'étais